thank you everyone for having me here
today I'll tell you a little bit about
myself and then I'll tell you a little
bit more about ggv and what we do and so
I started my career as an undergrad at
Rutgers
so rocker2 University in New Jersey I
studied art history an econ while was
there I had worked for a credit agency
called Moody's who did the credit scores
for a lot of the debt and a lot of the
bonds that companies would hold and
countries and sovereign sovereign funds
would also have as well and so I cover
specifically consumer goods and retail
while I was in school then the market
crashed and then I went off and actually
started my career in Teach for America
so I was in I was a core member there
and I taught middle school private a
special ed and general education for
middle school students all subjects for
a couple years then I became a school
administrator decided to go back to I
got my masters in education especially
at that time decided to go back into
finance and I went to University of
Chicago for my MBA during that time I
discovered a lot more around startups
and venture capital and that summer was
when I first started working in DC and
that was about five and a half years ago
so I've been in venture since and I've
been with ggv for a long time I started
working at chi-ming which is a venture
fund in China one of the first
institutional investors in Xiaomi with
Hans Tong who was there who I was
working with who now is that ggv who I
work alongside very closely with as well
is a good friend of Professor - Aires -
so tell you a little bit more about ggv
GV is a venture fund that has been
around for 18 years we primarily invest
across both US and China so two markets
we have done this starting from day one
our first office is in Menlo Park which
is where I am right now
about like 10 minutes from
on Sand Hill Road but we also have a
Shanghai office and a Beijing office we
manage now about 3.8 billion we have
many portfolio companies and 37 exits in
the in our portfolio so far so IPOs and
days and here's some of our highlighted
companies Olli follow we actually
invested in in 2003 so we saw kind of
the rise of platforms right and how that
scaled over time which was a huge
advantage for ggv to see that and be
able to spread that knowledge across
companies in the US and so we have a lot
of platforms on the consumer side like
wish offer up Airbnb on the travel side
to enterprise companies like Square and
slack we're on the board of and
musically that just exited last year
sold to total my kids and so we like
everything around consumer wrong urban
tech mobility to enterprise SAS and
lastly frontier tech IOT robotics and so
what I do specifically is I'm on the
investment team so help with building
out our investment thesis sourcing
companies doing diligence for companies
and investing in them and then
personally being on the board of
companies or helping support our
portfolio so I work with 28 companies
within ggv support folio I am on the
board of two companies and I'm a board
observer for fourteen of our portfolio
and happy to tell you more about them we
have time so just to give a quick update
specifically around US China I just
given what we do here are some
statistics that show kind of the growth
of what China has become today right and
as you can see one of the leading
factors that China has over the u.s. is
room one of course population but the
rise of smart phone and mobile first
users in China and so ecommerce
transactions
and e-commerce / nutrition because they
were a mobile-first country and a lot of
other countries in Southeast Asia are
also following this pattern right of
China are now you know a clear leader
here and you can see even penetration
wise for e-commerce is more than double
that in the US and that trend continues
to kind of go even faster mobile
payments for example is like ten times
bigger in China obvious most of you who
are from China obviously use WeChat and
I'll I pay and we we chat pay and the
most surprising I think statistic that
people have seen is the number of
unicorns that are in China and so
unicorns we call them as companies that
are valued over a billion dollars and
you can see how this has already
starting to tilt two years ago I mean in
end of last year we had about 98
unicorns in China and close to it's just
a little over a hundred in the US and so
this divide has this gap has really
closed in and China are creating much
bigger companies now and there's a lot
of funding involved as well and so you
can see that 218 billion in BC PE
funding went into China catching up with
the US and we believe that will actually
surpass in the next few years so just to
reiterate on that point like us used to
have about 81 percent of all VC
investments and all the dollars going
into this innovation but now that has
shifted to 54 percent in 2016 a lot of
that obviously went to China but a lot
of it is also going to emerging markets
as well just just to reiterate on this
point we as a fun are actually looking
into Southeast Asia or more broadly we
have done investments in Singapore like
we're investors in grab and so we are
looking heavily in Indonesia in Thailand
and other other parts of Southeast Asia
for opportunities oh this picture didn't
show up but it was really a collage of
faces from the Forbes - list so this
list is comes out every year of like the
top 100 investors in the world in
venture capital and so this year was the
first year where we saw the number-one
VC in the world was Neil Shannon from
Sequoia China and five years ago no one
from China was even on the four Midas
list and so we saw 16 VCS out of 100
were from China and a lot of them were
actually have ties with firms in the US
as well and so ggv has two on there Hans
Tong and Jenny Lee who's been on there
for for many years now actually but we
have seen a lot of other other companies
make it as well especially because the
list now is starting to recognize that a
lot of the unicorns are coming from
China
not just us anymore so that needs to be
factored in not to the list as well and
so I wanted to get into female
entrepreneurs in China specifically and
before that I wanted to start off with a
statistic around just the number of
people in China and a number of
graduates in China as well so the most
number of graduates that college
graduates in the world actually come
from India so 78 million graduates from
India last year there was 77 from 77
million from China so 1 million last and
US was actually at 67 million
graduates this was a you can look this
up on Forbes as well and this was a
statistic that was recently published
within stem grads specifically China
leads in the entire world
China has four point seven million stem
grads every year in math and science and
technology India followed by a half of
that at two point six u.s. is act
the only 586 thousand and Russia
following behind USF 561,000 so I want
to go into this framing just like the
size of the pool and like just giving
you some context around graduates in
general and so this goes through kind of
China's female population compared to
the u.s. obviously a little bit skewed
because of the one-child policy but that
is now relaxed we have actually more
female founders in China and then in the
US and a lot of that is attributed to
the fact that they have a lot more sub
grads as well four point five percent
female CEOs and female executives are
particularly high because of the amount
of consumer companies and e-commerce
companies in China compared to the u.s.
so you know Alibaba is so skewed much
more female than it is a male as well
and so a lot of that has been through a
lot the females that rose through the
ranks and what they are interested in as
well
and so here is some interesting stat
that was published recently about female
entrepreneurs a lot of them actually
have gone abroad and more Western
educated and and come back to China and
to do more and here are the most popular
fields where a few more entrepreneurs
tend to thrive in China we actually
invest in a lot of in these categories
in China as well and so in total the
female founders in China have raised
almost six billion dollars since 2013
and here are some notable female
entrepreneurs in China as well so ddu is
one of our portfolio companies as well
as shanshu which you know achar win is a
Stanford alum
by dance is at 73 hours also our
portfolio so in total we actually I
counted we have 13 female co-founders or
CEOs in our portfolio in China and we
actually only have 10 in the US so that
that's a little bit of a background
around kind of what we're seeing in
China as well and compared to the u.s.
yeah okay so yeah we can kind of let the
projector go off we'll be talking for
the rest of the session so there's two
big things first of all I'd like to talk
a little bit about China in general and
then I want to talk more about the
situation of women involved in the
entrepreneurial ecosystem okay so we see
the amazing statistics what would you
say about evaluating potential
investments that are in China versus
here in the US you've got a really
international portfolio can you use the
basically exactly the same process or do
you have to make some changes so the way
we make decisions is we invest as one
fund so we have a global committee when
we look at deals which is very unique to
actually most cross-border funds so
every Monday night we'll sit together
and we'll talk about deals on both sides
it still turns out to be about like 50%
of you know of the dollars go to us 50%
in China but the way we look at it is
still the same principles around kind of
market a market opportunity right
especially around the team and so
detailed question for the companies in
China do they all have their materials
in English sure that if you leave them
in Chinese they do not but our internal
materials are all in English okay okay
now I asked because I remember some
years ago talking to people about
companies got better valuations if they
could put their
into English this was you know some
years ago in China and so I'm but I'm
really seeing just the scale of VC
investing going up so much in China the
size of exits looks very similar to the
ones that during the United States it's
really grown up almost like the American
system in just an amazingly short amount
of time
does that make things difficult for ggv
are you having more competition for good
deals or are you still able to leverage
kind of early mover advantage I think
it's definitely very competitive in
China and even more so than the US on
heels we've seen just valuations creep
up way more there's much more inflated
in China than it is here just because of
the sheer amount of dollars that are in
the ecosystem we also see that we also
see you know the way we look at
companies in the u.s. change over time
as well because because we because US is
you know a population of about 300
million people right and a lot of the
companies we invest in the u.s. if we
want them to really be a big company and
be you know more than just a unicorn
they would actually have to be a very
global company and so for example ggb
investment or being me and has helped
Airbnb very closely with China
operations and helped them set up their
China office hire China hire into the
China team and so that strategy and for
Airbnb it's not about just capturing you
know other visitors globally going into
China but what they want to do is
capture the China outbound tourism
market right because as China opens up
more and more people will have more
money to go abroad and try new things
and that's where everybody can thrive
and so we see this dynamic of like how
can we leverage what we learned in China
our know-how for our English for our
us-based investments a lot of the times
China companies are not yet ready to go
from China to us but there's a lot more
of a China a US companies wanting to go
into China
those ggv have any kind of standard
strategic sort of guidelines are you
focusing on any particular areas or any
particular domain industry domains yeah
so more broadly we focus on three areas
one being consumer Internet so consumer
Internet is what I focus all my time in
that is ecommerce that's you know
ecommerce infrastructure so from like
payments perspective to security on that
front to social media digital media as
well as travel and and also cross-border
fits very well into this bucket as well
so anything that either has supply chain
in China or have customers in China or
vice versa so were you directly involved
in investing in grab I was not that was
our China team okay okay
how do you see Southeast Asia we we are
definitely seeing a lot of opportunity
there we don't have anyone on the ground
there today
I actually just hired an intern that is
from Indonesia and will work with us the
summer about it but haven't made that
investment yet it well what about
partners Jun is very involved in
Southeast Asia especially because he's
from Singapore Jenny is also from
Singapore as well so we have a lot of
ties okay before I go on to talk about
the other project that's the topic of
women I've got kind of a sort of
off-the-wall question for you so 3.5
billion under management at ggv which is
a very good you know large venture
capital firm what do you think about
soft banks 93 billion dollar vision fund
is that VC or is that really something
different it's not VC because I mean
that the type of dollars they want to
deploy and no ownership they want to
have is also quite different okay so we
see that as like the new eye
okay for a new way for early investors
to exit and that's like exactly what
they've been doing okay Wow so it's
really more like exits when they throw a
billion dollars at something yeah said
well it depends on like what type of an
investor you are when you know you came
in but but what they're doing is a very
interesting strategy around investing in
multiple competitors know so that they
will merge them together that is their
key under yeah I keep thinking up things
I was noticing 4,900 give or take exits
in China last year and about 750 in the
US why so many more in China any ideas
or is that just timing or a very active
ecosystem I think it's very very active
ecosystem for sure just like a lot of
aquifers and the way that the teams it
the way that b8e invests in China is
very different from how Fang operates in
the US right and so like the Baidu all
the 10 cent of the world and there's a
new generation of that as well but like
they were actively invest alongside VCS
and not exert like too much control but
they've leveraged them quite a bit and
then eventually like you saw recently
that made you know the ulema except
right and so with us if you are invested
by Google or Facebook and I said are all
like they tend not to want to do that
and people tend to shy away because
they're like well then it's a strategic
and though just know everybody okay
there are people familiar with the term
aqua hire okay so if what you're really
doing is getting the people to come to
work for you more than the business that
the company is doing when you acquire
the company you're really acquiring the
people so it's a choir
anyway that's you hear this now kind of
moving on to the discussion of women the
first statistic that you had before you
started using the slides about how many
women in stem are graduating from unit
and in the United States it was like 586
thousand yeah okay
oh that's men and women graduating in
stem okay but still in China four point
seven million graduating so if you
figure that the population of time is
about four times as big as that of
America you still have a lot higher
percentage of the population involved in
stem in China yeah that's right do you
think that's going to continue do you
think that this is a temporary kind of
thing I think that will continue
especially given how much say the
government has in what you study yeah
okay a lot of like the tests determine
what type of major you're going into
right and where you're gonna go to
school and so think I mean actually from
that standpoint it's been a plus uh-huh
for the economy so let's start with the
United States they're not many women who
are in venture capital firms in the US
right they're not and is that situation
what does that feel like on the ground
do you feel like you're the only woman
in a lot of meetings it's a pro actually
a lot of times because you know we bring
something completely different to the
table especially if you invest in
certain categories for firming I invest
in consumer and majority of consumer
decisions are made by women and the
family right or you know they just spend
a lot more in general and so when I
pitch companies or explain companies the
partnership it really brings a very
different perspective that you know
instead of a partner having to ask their
wives or their daughters if they use the
certain company or product we actually
have a lot a lot more research so listen
to your background I feel like you
should be about you know 55 or 60 years
old
do you have trouble with getting people
to take you seriously when you walk into
a new
I look very young
which you know is a good thing too but
but I I haven't I haven't had that issue
with entrepreneurs okay okay oh what
about other venture capitalists calls on
you have to coordinate a lot and you
have to syndicated a lot I would say as
a female I have encountered you know
certain hardships before and especially
in the boardroom we've had Co invested
in a in Europe with a European investor
a board member who was maybe 70 plus
years old very different and just asked
for me not to be there because that was
a female Wow okay how did you handle
that situation I mean I did I wasn't
observers I wasn't actually a board
member
okay um so I ended up working very
closely with the CEO instead outside of
the boardroom but you know that that
still happens today just happened like
less than two years ago do you sense a
difference in the attitudes in China
than the attitudes here these are
positive in China or negative in China I
think I think women everywhere still has
a lot of challenges but I would say that
because there's a lot of stuff geysers
in China there's a lot of women in
finance particularly so there's actually
a lot of women in MPE a VC in China as
well if you are talking to a young
person who is interested in going into
this kind of venture financing would you
have advice for them yeah I think one be
always curious and passionate about
learning so one of the things in venture
is that you don't specialize the moment
you start right so a lot of times you're
a generalist so I when I worked at
Flextronics which is a venture arm of
which is which was at in their venture
arm I was covering a IOT and I was
covering security and it was like a very
different field than what I'm
today but you have to be able to learn
all that talk to experts I get smart
about it and just read about that type
of news all the time and so being broad
and being stating in tune with what
you're doing and what you're learning is
very important but second of all is
about VC is so much about networking
yeah so you have to want to spend your
whole day in meetings and like talking
to people talking to entrepreneurs
talking to other VCS other X X Google
alums right or others that come out of
this so okay that's great why don't we
open the floor to questions I have a few
more rolled up but once I give people in
the audience a chance go ahead you first
so the question was what can you pick up
an venture capital right yeah that is
really unique that you can't pick up at
any other kind of job a lot of venture
is about reading people right and the
team so a lot of times if you have a
great idea but a bad team you just would
never become big right so it's really
about seeing patterns in people and
seeing like how hungry the people are
right what is the motivation behind them
why do they want to do the startup and
and see if they're really in it for the
long haul and do they have that tenacity
to do it
and so I would actually say there's not
really that much skill involved in
venture other than that because one in
the early side there's nothing for you
to model right there's there's just not
that many numbers right you can
guesstimate on the large later rounds
it's all about the numbers so that's all
you're really doing is can the math make
sense and so I think VC is so much
around about people and like making the
right bets but really at the right time
so is that an intuition matter
is that something where you get a
feeling or how do you deal with that at
the early stages when you can't model
yeah I think a lot of it is you and the
partners intuition but learning from but
going back and learning from your
mistakes so we have we've actually
passed on this series a of Airbnb like
that it was very painful right and we
passed on uber very early on and so you
know being able to go back and say well
why didn't we invest what did we do
wrong how can we not make that mistake
in the future it's something that like
we actively have to do all this well
there used to be this really funny
website called did not invest calm you
know all the companies like Google that
you know people didn't invest in are
there a lot of disagreements about
investments
when you get together because it has to
go through a panel right yes okay
depends on the phone but our firm yes it
is by vote but I think you I'd say like
there will never be a good deal when
everyone agrees and so it's it's good to
go back and forth and really debate
around the most controversial companies
okay thanks you had a question
I really enjoyed your presentation I'm
curious about what type of value
companies are looking for from from VC
partners and from your experience on the
boards you serve the the 28 companies
you work with the CEO you just share
that you work more closely with the
board is right into the board itself
what are they actually looking for kind
of value or in the control or the VC
partner your experience so very briefly
the question and I'm doing this cause
we're on video take them they may not be
picking you up the quarter of the values
that a firm looks at from the VC that
they hope to get from the VC through the
investment yeah so one I think VC is
supposed to be a trusted adviser to the
startup and so what are the things that
we provide it's just like the
the broader perspective right because as
a start-up you really heads down in the
moment with what you're doing all the
time but we actually see before we made
your decision to invest in you we
probably saw 10 of you right and we
continue to see more of that coming up
in that same I'm talking about saying
business model right probably see my
similar idea similar space and so we're
able to provide like the insights on
that front of like hey what's happening
in the front of market what are the
trends that we're seeing what and then
second we know how companies scale and
so we see that we anticipate a lot of
the problems that you'll run into right
when do you need to upgrade your team
right when should you start getting dead
when like how do you think about your
next fundraise right and so a lot of
that because we've seen even like the
biggest growth globally were able to be
able to provide that that help and
knowledge right to our CEOs as well and
so actually spend a lot of my time
hiring for our portfolio so I interview
a lot of executives that we will bring
onto the board onto the executive team
for the company so earlier today was
interviewing a CMO of one of the public
companies who we want to get into our
portfolio and so we do a lot of that as
well
and so thought leadership and so that's
something kind of worth drilling down on
a little bit but cause she was email you
know okay but you know first of all this
happens a lot right you get a lot of
people who can grow a company from 0 to
30 or 40 people and then you need a
different set of people to grow them to
300 does the VC have to break the bad
news or how does this work
well sometimes uh it's usually the VC no
I I think because a lot of times
especially founders your founding team
you've been through so much together
it's really hard to let go
we actually have an instance where this
has happened in our is happening in our
portfolio right now and really been
wanting to have the CEO upgrade his team
and that is the number one mistakes that
all startups have is not being able to
fire fast enough and not being able to
hire fast enough right the right people
yeah yeah so this person with the public
company is a woman right you just so is
it going to be difficult to get her to
come to the portfolio compensation wise
probably uh-huh but with the right fit I
think it could happen especially and you
think a lot of this is like setting it
up in the right way right because they
may start off as an advisor right get
close to the company we might if we
can't get her as a CMO she might become
an independent board member so there's
other ways that hopefully we can but
basically this is a very mobile
population the executives they're
willing to jump yes if they have the
right incentive package yeah okay okay
because that's something that we had I
had trouble with I was working on a big
science and technology program for the
Government of Canada and when we found
the people that we really wanted to
bring in and give grants to we couldn't
get women to go to Canada which was sort
of you know a difficult outcome for us
and a lot of it had to do with the
family situations but we're asking
people to move a long way away right
so in these innovation centers it's a
very mobile workforce already yeah okay
go ahead about the female like the
leadership kind of things so how he
handled the kind of to deal with the
balance between young I mean the family
and the business I mean there are so
many female like us entrepreneurships
right now but they have to get married
yet like give birth to the baby so
balance
so the question is really balancing work
life right how do you balance the
biological functions that women have
with you know a career do you sacrifice
yeah those problems are real like we've
seen some of our exacts from portfolio
companies like leave after giving birth
by and wanting to become a stay-at-home
mom and we have to respect that and so I
think I think what one thing in China
that actually is a bit more helpful is
like that there's a lot of family
support actually with with among the
parents and the in-laws so even one of
our other VPS in China as she recently
gave her yeah okay great yeah and so she
she made oh she's making it work I mean
it's definitely not easy but like having
family support and being like being sure
about your priorities and you you know
something has to budge but like I think
we still were so very involved she's
very involved and she should be still
today and so definitely not an easy task
but I think I think sometimes especially
in our own startup portfolio you're the
like some of the females are the first
ones to create the policy so I think a
lot more people are now open to helping
women and giving both maternity and
paternity leave and we see that a lot of
in tech and being able to you know lead
that as well you can other go ahead how
do you think the recent Facebook issues
in terms of selling data as the
previously discussed so the problems of
selling data and the privacy issues
how's that going to affect the sector
right the industry sector yeah I mean I
think it'll there'll be definitely a lot
more scrutiny I can't comment too much
on it but yeah you know in Europe it's
way more strict in terms of privacy
rules then
is in the US and so perhaps we might
lean closer to that but hard to say
right now mark I don't know if you saw
marks livestream on Congress today on
Facebook
I mean ironic that it was but but yeah
if you didn't see it go back and watch
it I saw maybe an hour and a half of it
it's actually people are actually very
willing to share data in China because
they know that they can get something
out of it in return right and so I think
most of the such toship it really just
comes from the government as opposed to
like people acting on it and I don't
know how what do you think says you're
all of China as well a lot of you do you
do you see it being an issue I like the
culture difference
so for West Warren like well oh thank
you a kind of cultural policy kind of
says oh we're not that aware of them
five inches of help ourselves okay good
let's move to a different question there
you are so the question is really about
the your background in the education
industry and how did that impact what
you're doing now how you approach your
work now and the kind of personal
fulfillment
that people will say it's my passion but
whether it's real passion like how to
identify any other words I didn't know
was doing all of this there once I was
doing yeah I I'll get a little bit real
about like why I joined Teach for
America
so I I was born in Hong Kong I came to
the US when I was little in elementary
school and grew up in Lilan and then in
New York and then Jersey and I didn't
become a u.s. citizen until I was in
middle school and I was actually very
very lucky that my parents had brought
me into a very good school district in
New Jersey and and New Jersey has among
the top public schools in the in the US
and and I actually graduated with a
one-year one one year of college already
done through high school because I was
able to take a lot of these AP courses
and these honors classes there right and
that gave me a lot of credits to go into
college and I felt like when I learned
about what was happening as with
education in the u.s. it just felt very
I felt very privileged and I felt very
lucky right and so was Teach for America
was a way for me to kind of give back
get back my time because for someone
who's not a US citizen and who got even
better education than somebody else here
right I felt like I owed a lot to kind
of the teachers and the people and it's
always like a major reason of why like I
ended up doing TFA and actually turned
out because that's how I met my husband
but I think it's definitely I don't
think anything else would be more
emotionally satisfied fine right then
like helping a group of students as you
know and and actually very interesting
statistics as as you as you saw in the
graduates 500 something in the 500 that
something thousand in the u.s. only 30
percent of US adults
have a college degree so just like that
was something that I recently discovered
just among my my trip across the u.s.
just digging digging deeper into
statistics and so like I I always think
about like how fortunate we are right
about that but in terms of like moving
on to the investment side there's
actually a lot of similarities because a
lot of the companies that we we help
fund are helping entrepreneurs fulfill
their dreams right and we're helping
them grow more alongside them and
creating jobs and opportunities
hopefully for the better or not for the
waters actually that's a great answer
go ahead Island yeah you obviously see a
lot of startup companies in in Asia and
North in u.s. is that or not for do also
are you have an interest in Europe in
the Nordics where I come from there's an
explosion of startups these days and
some very interesting companies so yeah
you look at Europe as well and or you
really focus on on Asia and us we do
have a couple of portfolio companies in
Europe but our main focus it's just us
in China just given our bandwidth if we
don't have our presence in Europe
physically it's hard for us to really be
helpful to the entrepreneurs and I think
that doesn't do as much justice to the
companies there especially if you know
they need the hiring they need that
local network the business development
so that was like a bigger reason of why
it's not that we would never do a
European investment but it would have to
be like we can't be the lead or
something in particular as a market and
bringing technology to China so that
seems to be perhaps some opportunities
for sure yeah there's actually even a
lot of bike sharing companies right now
in Europe right and have taken a similar
approach to what's happening in China
and here and should we see some of
models business models from China going
into Europe as well as a lot of interest
of European companies going into China
let me kind of take that in a slightly
different direct
and I see a lot of regions in China
especially like Shingen and kind of
investors in China who would love to
attract startup companies from outside
China to go and set up shop in China
does ggv do you are you pushing for that
or how do you see that trend he'd be
pushing our startups to to do that you
know I I think only when starts already
we wouldn't encourage them to go and one
of they're not but we've we've taken a
lot of them we do like CEO trips so
we've brought a lot of our CEOs last
October to China from the US on a tour
of multiple cities we did that from
Chinese CEOs coming here so we do a lot
of that cross-pollination are you seeing
more startup companies that are kind of
going global at early stages yeah I
think it's a lot easier nowadays than it
used to be I'm particularly consumer I
wouldn't say that for enterprise no I'm
just just the nature of that industry
but like in consumer and e-commerce and
and like social media for example
definitely like you're the world is your
oyster II like you you know you can just
ship anywhere
globally nowadays very easily besides
the kind of difference in platforms so
so much smartphone moving ahead in Asia
are there other differences in
e-commerce behavior between people in
Asia and people here yeah I think one of
the funny thing is I asked the other day
because I think I was wearing I must
have been wearing a startup t-shirt but
I asked like oh and China are people
like really loyal to you know to you
know ten cent or Olli and wear wear
clothes that represent them because in
here you know the coveted Google Google
hats right or that Facebook t-shirt and
and actually people were like we don't
have an affinity we just want whatever
is the most come
it's whatever is the easiest for me to
use and I will I will just use whatever
it is and so it's kind of funny like
that difference of like you go ahead you
first what is the percentage and then
then what metrics do you use to evaluate
this is a great country yeah so the
sourcing of deals how many come to you
versus how many are you really looking
for yeah so um in the past four years I
was up in HGTV I've I've seen over
fifteen hundred deals at lease that I've
recorded that I had notes on so we look
at a lot of companies and a lot of that
and that's just me alone
and a lot of that is inbound for sure
but we also and this is fun to fund is
different we we do a lot of investment
thesis so we actually look at a sector
every six months we come up with a
thesis around like this is what we want
to deep dive into here are all the
companies in the space why do we like
the space or not can we verify you know
is this the right opportunity and so for
example I'm looking in health and
wellness as a category and so I would
look at what are the drivers of this
this industry why now right like what is
the investment opportunity here and then
I would actually dig up all the
companies in this space that would be
relevant to my thesis and then I will
seek them out actually I use LinkedIn
probably more than any other reading any
other social platform and so they spend
a lot of time doing that and a lot of
outreach and the inbound ones may or may
not be core to what we're looking at so
we don't always see them but but yeah
that that's the general mix I would say
but every one is a little bit different
because GE tends to lead a lot of deals
right we don't we don't get shared deal
flow as much except for some earlier
funds right because we're not going to
be brought in - hey do you want to do
this deal
it's more like hey does Jujubee want to
leave this deal right so so with like
1500 deals and out of these now you're
working with 28 companies yeah so that's
a pretty severe ratio what are the kind
of the really big key thing that maybe
especially entrepreneurs would miss yeah
and one of the one of the biggest things
for us is like just how global and how
big is that opportunity and if it's not
a global opportunity we probably won't
invest just just given the nature of our
fun just see what we see between US and
China and if the team does not have that
ambition it's very hard to change the
CEO and that doesn't mean that it won't
be a good outcome right like we I met
this company who you know the CEO was
probably gonna pocket 100 million
dollars like that's great for them they
should they should do that and not raise
so yeah okay go ahead you you're next
you know in Southeast Asia in Asia in
Europe so there are you know microcosms
of PCs in every single continent and
place and there's a lot of mushrooming
of micro VCS and accelerators and you
know the ecosystem has grown rapidly so
when we're talking about US China and US
Asia it sort of seems like we are in
this microcosm of us and you know what
other than money can a venture capital
really provide because the bridge
between these two continents it's just
such a you know it's all sort of so
isolated now like you said if you are
not in Europe you are not doing justice
to be part of the ecosystem there if
you're not in Southeast Asia you are
hiring an intern there that still seems
a little difficult even though you have
some members that are from there but are
probably based here yeah I think your
comment is getting to be very broad and
ranging okay so I'd like to pick one
part of that to start with and that is
that venture capital has really grown
drastically and
certain rather small kind of regional
innovation systems right microcosms and
I think that one kind of sort of obvious
question is are they sophisticated or
are they really kind of dangerous
because they don't know what they're
doing yet hard hard for me to comment on
that acutely but I think I think there's
a lot of there's a lot of funds in those
areas like Sequoia India right who have
the lessons of some other other regions
right to be able to bring back one of
the things that that you know we bring
value wise to that region is one lessons
of models and business models that
worked in the US and I can that be
transferable there and lessons learned
and then with the China piece also the
same way but a lot of the startups there
actually hire a lot of Chinese talent
and Chinese people who come from China
and go into you into Southeast Asia or
want to do business from Southeast Asia
to China and so we see a lot of that
flow and so I think from that standpoint
it is so it's really a rapid rise in the
sophistication of the venture capital
community and a lot of it is because
people are going and helping others to
see the lessons yeah and I think it just
if you still need some time to see like
bigger funds to be able to do larger
rounds because there hasn't you need to
see those bigger exits in order for that
to happen and so what you're so we're
still waiting for that but it is amazing
to me to see how quickly it's grown yeah
especially in terms of dollars yeah
okay go ahead location question
I wonder how important is that the
specific location of a company within
the country you to invest let's say does
the company to be in Silicon Valley or
in Beijing or from height or you're
really not that important oh it doesn't
so we have a lot of profile companies
across the u.s. so for example we have a
lot we have four
portfolio companies in New York we have
a company in Austin we have a company
and Denver right we have a company in
Seattle and companies in LA so did you
actually have to be in the valley we
travel to them as well
are you starting to see more interesting
companies in the tier 2 and tier 3
cities in China
are they all going to Shanghai and
Beijing in shading and the mega cities
but targeting yeah search for their
business okay okay other questions go
ahead because your happen I studied in a
t-shirt holy crap
why not open is that you see in
Indonesia for five or ten years ahead as
you are in Japanese so the question is
opportunities for five or ten years I
had great success five or ten years from
now in Indonesia things that you as a
venture capitalist you would be
especially interested in so for us is
Allah around like Commerce and payments
for sure we think that being a
mobile-first economy has very much
similar ties to how China has grown from
from its rise but that and so if you
know if political unrest is not there
and everything is okay in five to ten
years I think that there's definitely a
lot of opportunity to see new innovation
around even like Kojak for example is
going into payments right and doing a
lot more and so I think there's a lot
going to be a lot of innovation around
commerce and consumption if you think
about it like e-commerce penetration in
the whole wide world is less than 20%
and so of all retail right and so its
own that number is only gonna go up over
time and that is why we are big
believers and continue to invest
ecommerce because we don't think that
Amazon or Olli it's gonna capture all
that opportunity everywhere great you
had a question what is this what is your
take on any market as I mean India's
going and a very good to grow trade and
it's a it's a sort of a flowing period
so are you keen on investing in India
our is GTV investing in India was that
that was right your questions
we've looked very closely at India for a
number of years we are not currently
investing in India right now I think I
think market perspective is still a bit
still bit underdeveloped and a lot of it
is is just like GDP per capita and more
the rise of like the middle class needs
to come up a bit more before we see more
opportunities actually Hans one of our
partners was angel investor and flip car
and Snapdeal and in the unsewn very
close with India for a long time and we
just haven't been able to make an
investment yet okay other questions if
we're about getting to the end of the
questions I think we've got some
refreshments outside and we can all have
a more informal conversation at that
point I want to thank you Robin for
giving us a really candid and great
insider view of what this world is like
especially you know what was happening
with this the role of women in an
industry where they haven't had a great
you know much presence in the United
States so I really appreciate it thank
you very much
[Applause]
you